les hommes mais soucieux de leur
élégance de leur look comme on dit
maintenant ne vont certes pas manquer le
salon européen de la mode masculine qui
s'est ouvert pour quatre jours ce matin
à paris pour guider l'aspiration des
couturiers une étude tout à fait
nouvelle du comportement des français
fait par le cca le centre de
communication avancée à noron gère a
suivi ces messieurs attention ceci n'est
pas un défilé de mode
vous allez voir seul style de vêtements
être consommation à vous de vous situer
ici l'art le cas achète par impulsion
pour surprendre et séduire
à l'opposé voici l'ambassadeur à droite
et son petit camarade le brummel à
gauche panoplie de base le costume trois
pièces style d'achat surtout pas de coup
de foudre très sensible aux griffes et
aux marques
bref le vêtement comme signe de réussite
sociale quatrième type le shérif en
pantoufles ici version macho il ya aussi
la version père tranquille
objectif numéro un le confort style
d'achat il craque parfois pour une
petite folie mais il a horreur d'acheter
ses vêtements lunettes
sauf les sous vêtements enfin cinquième
et dernier type l'homme des bois
ils achètent au hasard car pour lui la
mode c'est un piège une espèce en voie
de disparition
en 77 l'époque du punk un des plus
jeunes punks de france ça veut dire
quelque chose avait 16 ans en 82 avec le
smurf ils ont 12 ans aujourd'hui ils ont
huit ans c'est à dire que à 8 ans ont
déjà une idée très précise de ce qu'ils
veulent autrement dit les regards
d'autres ailleurs que de ce que veut
leur maman et les des marques comme ça
qu'ils sont totalement inconnu pour moi
ou pour vous et puis qui pour les 8 12
ans et des must absolu
il ya aussi des musts au niveau de la
couleur deux ans à l'avancé bureau de
style planifie pour l'été 87
un raz de marée de beige et de kaki
surtout pas de jaune vif
c'est prouvé les français ne supportent
pas en revanche le madr a qui a été un
échec retentissant cette année sera
relancé à dose homéopathique rentabilité
oblige qu'il faut bien écouler les
stocks
on sait ce qui se vend bien chaque
saison ce qui se vend mal ce qui se
voudront ce qui semble bien se
développer mes capacités assez
développée on en tient compte dans nos
éléments donc déjà en fait évoluer ce
qui a bien marché en le conservant ce
côté les chirac commercial alors déjà il
ya toute une partie qu'on conserve et
conques ont fait évoluer sans la
transformer et puis ensuite on importe
les éléments nouveaux qui sont là pouf
et revend vous finalement pour changer
le look et 2
au delà du marketing qu'on finit un peu
de rêve tout même
le look des années 90 vu par kenzo en
attendant que la mode descendent dans la
rue
retour à la grisaille